merci d'être avec nous Renan Paul Savary
nous accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu de la Marne
membre du groupe les républicains
rapporteur du budget de la Sécurité
sociale dont on va longuement parler
dans quelques instants mais d'abord on
l'a vu dans le journal face à la
virulence de l'épidémie de bronchiolite
François bronin a annoncé hier devant
les sénateurs le déclenchement d'un plan
exceptionnel pour l'hôpital prévu dans
des situations sanitaires
exceptionnelles est-ce que c'est
suffisant pour soulager le système face
à cette épidémie écoutez une épidémie et
l'hôpital craque donc ça montre bien que
un certain nombre de difficultés ce plan
permet de mobiliser le personnel de
façon à l'adapter aux besoins donc c'est
une charge supplémentaire peu
personnelle mais également de
déprogrammer un certain nombre d'actes
vous voyez on en revient à ce qu'on a
connu au moment du covid ce qui montre
bien que notre structure hospitalière
n'est plus adaptée maintenant faut faire
attention il faut pas emmener tous les
enfants systématiquement à l'hôpital la
bronchiolite c'est quelque chose moi en
tant que médecin que plus connu tous les
ans et qui se soigne bien et sans
antibiotique d'ailleurs et n'envoie ne
vont à l'hôpital que les enfants qui
présentent un certain nombre de troubles
donc consultés je le dis aux parents
consulter le médecin ne vous affolez pas
mais parce que les symptômes sont
parfois impressionnants et les choses
devraient se passer correctement dès
l'instant où on arrive bien entendu à
trouver un médecin et c'est la question
on va évidemment parler de la question
des déserts médicaux dans quelques
instants mais on a vu par exemple
pendant l'année du covid avec les
chaises barrières très respectés qui
avaient pas
d'épidémie de gastro-entérite est-ce que
avant d'en arriver au stade où les
enfants sont obligés d'aller à l'hôpital
il faut pas revenir à des mesures comme
rendre le port du masque obligatoire
dans certains lieux mais écoutez ce
serait une mesure de bon sens il me
semble qu'en période hivernale faut
qu'on arrive à prendre cette habitude de
prendre un certain nombre de de distance
quand il y a de la proximité et les
mesures simples se laver les mains parce
que c'est comme ça que se et notamment
un certain nombre de virus et également
porter le masque dans des lieux où on
est en proximité et on pense au
transport en commun vous voyez c'est des
mesures de prévention que je ce qui
serait me semble-t-il bienvenue qui
serait peut-être difficile à reprendre
mais qui me pénaliserait pas tout le
monde en cas d'aggravation de cette
épidémie ou d'autres quand la grippe moi
je pense qu'il devrait les prendre et je
pense souvent on aura là l'occasion
d'interpeller encore le ministre de la
Santé là-dessus parce que c'est
maintenant qu'il faut les prendre c'est
même trop tard je dirais parce que
l'épidémie est déjà largement développée
mais demain ça va être la
ghostro-entérite après demain ça va être
la grippe avec une recrudescence
maintenant de ces pathologies vernales
qu'on connaît bien il faut les prévenir
puis surtout travailler leur la
recherche parce que l'idéal c'est
d'avoir le médecin contre le vaccin
contre la bronchiolite et on sait que ça
va venir bientôt mais pas cette année
encore un dernier mot là-dessus puisque
vous le dites déclenchement c'est aussi
révélateur de l'état de nos hôpitaux au
début de l'examen du budget de la
Sécurité sociale François Braun a
annoncé une enveloppe de 800 millions
d'euros c'était 150 initialement puis
400 là il a dit ce sera 600 millions
d'euros pour aider les services en
tension vous avez fort peu goûté à la
méthode ça vous a un petit peu exaspéré
mais le fond est là il y a pas que
l'argent il y a la reconnaissance
l'organisation il y a vraiment un
certain nombre de choses à transformer
dans la médecine hospitalière mais
également dans la médecine de ville on
l'abordera peut-être tout à l'heure en
conséquence c'est pas à travers le PLFSS
qu'on va faire ça c'est un document
budgétaire c'est une vraie loi santé
d'organisation de la santé des Français
qu'il faut c'est ce que l'on réclame
on va parler justement de ce budget de
la Sécurité sociale on va revenir sur
cette question de déserts médicaux vous
avez poursuivi hier soir et cette nuit
l'examen de ce budget on va voir les
temps forts de ces dernières heures de
séances avec Steve Jordan
[Musique]
du budget de la Sécu se poursuit au
Sénat le Sénat qui a dit oui au
gouvernement sur les consultations de
prévention à différents âges de la vie
oui c'est l'un des grands symboles de ce
projet de loi dorénavant chacun pourra
bénéficier d'un rendez-vous dit de
prévention à différents âges de
différents âges clés de la vie des
rendez-vous qui seront entièrement pris
en charge par l'assurance maladie le
Sénat a dit oui effectivement mais
encadrer la mesure ne parlait pas de
rendez-vous de prévention parler plutôt
de consultation le Sénat a également
interdit le recours à la télémédecine
pour ce genre de visite les sénateurs
exigent enfin que ce soit le Haut
Conseil de la santé publique qui se
prononce sur le nombre et le contenu de
ces consultations et sur un autre point
phare de ce budget le Sénat dit oui mais
avec des réserves oui oui à la mise en
place d'une quatrième année d'internat
en médecine générale contre trois
actuellement il s'agit d'une année de
stage réalisé en ambulatoire c'est à
dire pas à l'hôpital mais chez un
médecin de ville l'objectif c'est de
lutter contre les déserts médicaux et
d'in à terme les étudiants à s'installer
dans ces zones écoutées il s'agit bien
sûr d'une réforme pédagogique qui est
souhaitable qui était d'ailleurs
souhaité même par les étudiants en
médecine il y a encore peu de temps et
qui améliorera la réponse aux besoins de
santé de demain aujourd'hui la médecine
générale est la seule spécialité
médicale à n'avoir que trois années de
formation et de ne pas pouvoir
bénéficier de cette phase de
consolidation sur le principe les
sénateurs disent oui mais ils veulent
que ce soit leur dispositif qui soit
mise en place oui parce que le 18
octobre dernier un texte proposé par le
patron du houppeler Bruno retailleux
avait été adopté la philosophie et la
même et les sénateurs considèrent que
leur rédaction est plus précise que
celle du gouvernement écouté
ce dispositif sera une réussite si les
gagnants gagnants gagnants pour
pour les interdit en médecine générale
parce qu'ils ne sont pas opposés à avoir
une année professionnalisation
gagnant par la reconnaissance de leur
titre de docteur junior évidemment
gagnant par un engagement aussi plus
fort des médecins généralistes installés
pour qu'ils soient encore plus nombreux
à être maître de stage et puis bien sûr
gagnant pour les patients parce que il y
aura du temps médical supplémentaire et
il n'y aura pas d'année blanche partage
la vie du ministre sur ce pain c'est
donc la version du Sénat qui a été
adoptée hier une mesure qui provoque la
colère des jeunes médecins
l'intersyndicales des internes a appelé
à manifester le 17 novembre pour le
retrait de cette proposition monsieur le
sénateur vous comprenez cette colère des
internes écoutez moi j'ai eu l'occasion
de recevoir et effectivement je
comprends je comprends que
si la mesure n'a pas été concertée
expliquée qui est une certaine colère
mais il faut aussi qu'ils comprennent
les internes que dans les territoires on
peut plus accepter qu'il y a plus de
médecin généraliste parce qu'il en a il
y va de la santé la raison pour laquelle
il y a eu hier soir au Sénat un coup de
semence un coup de semence il faut que
chacun fasse un pas dans le bon sens les
sénateurs représentants des territoires
n'acceptent plus c'est problème de sous
dotation dans leur territoire et il faut
que derrière l'ensemble de l'ordre des
médecins mais également des heures des
infirmiers après à travailler
différemment pour que la médecine
générale redevienne attractif c'est la
raison pour laquelle on a trouvé une
solution qu'on avait d'ailleurs proposé
qu'a pris le gouvernement une quatrième
année mais une quatrième année qui doit
être avec un maître de stage
universitaire c'est une année
pédagogique mais c'est une année où on
peut faire également des stages dans un
grand nombre de territoires qui sont
actuellement soudés et répondre aux
besoins c'est pas une sous-formation
c'est pas une punition mais attention
s'il y a pas de compromis de trouver il
y aura des mesures de scission qui vont
être prises nous nous avons
au Sénat non c'est pas une menace au
contraire c'est le coup de ça veut dire
que hier soir au Sénat nous avons évité
des mesures de coercition qui à mon
point de vue un point de vue largement
partagé d'ailleurs serait des mesures
qui effectivement pénaliseraient les
internes on va pas pénaliser la
génération d'aujourd'hui pour les
erreurs qui ont été commises depuis un
certain nombre d'années
il y a un interne qui se suicide toutes
les trois semaines toutes les trois
semaines est-ce que c'est à eux de payer
pour les défaillances de tout un système
ce problème qu'un problème grave n'est
pas dû à ce qu'on va proposer c'est le
fait que effectivement il y a un cursus
qui rencontre un certain nombre de
difficultés
ce qui est important c'est que dans la
conception de ce métier faut une
motivation particulière il faut derrière
à les rendre un service aux gens qui n'a
pas un service que l'on fait que la
journée c'est pas un service de 35
heures c'est un service de weekend de
jour de nuit de gars donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle c'est un engagement
faut qu'il soit bien formé pour cet
engagement et faut rendre après ce
métier encore plus attractif parce que
c'est un métier extraordinaire le métier
de médecine générale en conséquence faut
trouver des mesures qui incitent mais
qui ne pénalisent pas c'est la raison
pour laquelle moi j'avais proposé que
cette quatrième année qui est tout à
fait intéressante dans le troisième
cible qui va conduire à 10 ans d'études
alors que quand nous faisions nos études
nous étions à 7 ans nous diminuions
d'une année dans le premier cycle pour
rester à 9 ans il faut quand même
envisager qu'on peut pas faire quand
même des études de de dix années avec un
cursus qui permettrait peut-être de
réduire une réforme de cursus
beaucoup plus attractives sont gagnées
déjà une année sur les 6 premières dans
l'enseignement général vous dites on a
évité les mesures coercitives est-ce
qu'on va vraiment pouvoir encore s'en
passer longtemps de ces mesures ben
voilà la balle est vraiment dans le camp
du ministre hier soir on a voté quoi ce
qu'il proposait à savoir une discussion
au niveau des conventions les
conventions sont à mettre sur la table
et ont six mois là pour pour trouver une
solution et dans les conventions il y
aura le problème de l'installation de
ces médecins généralistes donc faut
trouver le juste compromis entre cette
difficulté vécue sur les territoires
inacceptables et le le la prise en
compte des difficultés des internes mais
ce que je voudrais faire comprendre
c'est que ils ont beaucoup de
difficultés de par l'implication que
l'on demande dans les hôpitaux mais ce
sera beaucoup plus humain et intéressant
peut-être d'aller dans des endroits et
d'être en contact direct avec des
patients et ils verront que ces
territoires sont des territoires dans
lesquels il fait bon vivre un
dernier c'est vrai qu'on en parle depuis
des années j'ai envie de vous dire de la
coordination entre médecine de ville et
médecine hos
pitale ça va mieux est-ce que c'est
réglé ce n'est pas entièrement réglé ça
mérite d'être amélioré il y a un certain
nombre de dispositions qui doivent être
faites nous avons également des
propositions pour faire en sorte
effectivement que les patients puissent
trouver une réponse à leurs problèmes
médical
on va parler de la réforme des retraites
évidemment puisque le Sénat va se
pencher sur cette réforme des retraites
c'est ça dans les heures à venir dans ce
budget de la Sécu que propose le Sénat
René Paul Savary qui revient une
nouvelle fois la charge sur ce dossier
vous proposez monsieur le rapporteur de
mettre en place une convention nationale
pour l'emploi des seniors et la
sauvegarde du système de retraite cette
convention serait composée des
partenaires sociaux de l'état des
associations familiales et de retraités
tous beau monde se met autour d'une
table se réunit pour faire des
propositions allant dans le sens d'un
maintien des seigneurs dans l'emploi
d'une prise en compte de la pénibilité
du travail du handicap et des carrières
longues ainsi que d'un retour à
l'équilibre de la branche vieillesse à
l'horizon 2033 si le constatation
fonctionne le gouvernement soumettrai le
résultat c'est-à-dire un texte au vote
du Parlement Oriane et si ça fonctionne
pas et ben on passe à la contrainte on
passe à la contrainte dans ce cas
monsieur Savary vous proposez une entrée
en vigueur d'une réforme des retraites
au 1er janvier 2024 réforme qui
consisterait alors on a un report de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite à 64
ans une accélération de la réforme
Touraine vous avez cette réforme qui
organise une augmentation progressive de
la durée de cotisation afin d'obtenir
une retraite à taux plein votre
proposition monsieur le sénateur vise
également à la convergence des régimes
spéciaux vers le régime général c'est un
amendement d'appel comme on dit dans le
jargon vous dites au gouvernement nous
sommes prêts pour votre réforme qui
arrivera au début de l'année prochaine
non c'est
une poursuite de ce que je propose au
nom de mon groupe tous les ans depuis je
crois 2014 c'est-à-dire que il faut
prendre des choses en main pour que
notre société et une vision différente
des seniors dans l'emploi nous sommes le
pays où nous avons un taux d'emploi des
seniors qui est le plus faible nous
sommes le pays où nous partons le plus
tard en retraite et nous sommes le pays
où nous avons un niveau de vie de
neurotraités qui est par rapport au
salaire moyen à peu près à égalité si on
veut faire en de ne pas travailler
jusque 65 ans c'est la différence que
l'on a avec Emmanuel Macron de ne pas
travailler jusqu'à 65 ans de faire
confiance aux partenaires sociaux le
leur donner le temps de discuter pour
prendre notamment l'adaptation si on
maintient dans l'emploi du seniors il
faut bien prendre en compte un certain
nombre de difficultés de handicap il y a
des mesures à prendre nous faisons
confiance aux partenaires sociaux pour
qu'ils en parlent pendant un an et à
l'issue de cela si effectivement il y a
pas de résultats on propose un certain
nombre de mesures des mesures qui
consistent simplement à pas travailler
plus longtemps 43 ans maximum donc les
générations plutôt pour être touchées et
un âge de départ qui serait modifié
pourquoi pourraient être comme les
autres pays européens en phase avec
l'augmentation de l'espérance de vie et
faire en sorte que l'effort qui serait
demandé
quelques mois supplémentaires par
génération ça se fait naturellement pour
être auto plein on sait que dans les
années qui viennent avec les mesures qui
ont déjà été prises les gens ne
partiront plus à 62 ans d'ailleurs il y
en a l'âge de départ moyen est déjà près
de 63 ans ce sera 64 ans progressivement
déjà avec les réformes actuelles on en
demandera pas plus simplement aussi une
aération du dispositif et là on arrive
grâce à cette à cet effort collectif en
faire en sorte qu'on puisse maintenir le
niveau de vie de ne retraités et que ces
mesures me semblent-ils peuvent être
acceptables sinon ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que les mesures seront
beaucoup plus brutales qu'il faudra
travailler encore plus longtemps et que
les retraites seront encore plus basses
on va revenir parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de choses dans ce que vous venez de nous
dire d'abord sur la question puisque
vous dites avec les réformes actuelles
ça conduit automatiquement un report de
l'âge de départ ça veut dire que la
gauche qui s'oppose à ce décalage de
l'âge légal vous lui dites en fait la
réforme Touraine ça conduit à ça il y a
une forme d'hypocrisie de la part de la
non je crois que la réforme avait été
habilement passée par Madame par Madame
le Ministre Touraine à l'époque bon moi
je veux pas faire de preuves c'est
l'attention ce que je veux c'est qu'on
trouve un dispositif qui redonne
confiance à nos jeunes de façon à ce
qu'on puisse leur permettre derrière
d'avoir une retraite parce que c'est ça
qu'il s'agit on peut pas dans un système
de répartition vivre à crédit sinon
c'est la mise en cause de la répartition
donc ça c'est une autre affaire soyons
attentif à cela et nous ne voulons pas
de retraités pauvre si on prend pas les
mesures maintenant c'est c'est pas de
report de l'âge de départ pour vous
c'est la fin du système de retraite à
répartition ou alors avec une baisse de
pension pour les retraités
augmentation des cotisations mais en
France c'est le pays où nous plaignons
déjà le plus de cotisations donc ça me
paraît pas la bonne mesure soit on
travaille un peu plus longtemps soit on
baisse le niveau des pensions oui tu
pourrais être trop compliqué après dans
le détail c'est un peu complexe avec nos
42 régimes qui n'empêche que ce que l'on
demande c'est quelque chose qui me
paraît tout à fait acceptable et plus on
tarde d'apprendre les mesures plus ce
sera brutal attention quand les
opposants de gauche notamment disent
mais il y a d'autres moyens d'augmenter
la légal de départ on peut aller trouver
l'argent ailleurs vous dites c'est pas
vrai non on peut toujours trouver des
solutions monsieur sera au détriment
d'autre chose et notamment si on paye
les retraites par la dette ça ne peut
pas tenir voilà alors par contre si on
veut maintenir les seniors en emploi il
y a un certain nombre de mesures
à prendre effectivement parce que ça
peut engendrer bien entendu c'est nous
sommes des des gens qui prenaient en
considération tout cela ça engendrer
d'autres types de difficultés mais ça se
fait dans les autres pays européens donc
il y a pas de raison qu'on ne trouve pas
de solution on va on va parler de
l'emploi des seigneurs parce que vous
avez fait un rapport sur sur cette
question de l'emploi des seigneurs là
aussi c'est une des critiques de cette
réforme des retraites qu'on entend c'est
si on met en place cette réforme des
retraites ça va être encore plus dur
pour les seniors qui déjà ont des
difficultés à maintenir leur emploi là
j'avançais qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
ça c'est-à-dire qu'il faut qu'on ait une
vision différente de la place des
seniors dans la société on peut pas dire
il faut équilibrer un système de
retraite et que les seniors soient la
variable d'ajustement des entreprises
faut faire attention à cela donc il y a
un effort de ce côté-là à faire et puis
d'autre part donc de la part des patrons
bien entendu et puis d'autre part les
seniors méritent également une formation
en fin de carrière faut pas dire à 60
ans c'est foutu non là il y a
véritablement des choses à faire après
faut adapter les maintenir dans l'emploi
c'est parfois trouver des solutions pour
qu'il fasse autre chose en fin de
carrière donc c'est là qu'il y a une
réflexion tout à fait pertinente à faire
et qui peut la faire mieux que les
partenaires sociaux parce que ils ont
l'ensemble il y a les les syndicats
patronaux les syndicats salariés et là
ils doivent trouver un compromis est-ce
qu'il faut des quotas pour les l'emploi
des seniors dans les entreprises c'est
une des pistes est-ce que pour vous
c'est une bonne piste non pour moi c'est
pas une bonne piste parce que quand on
commence à mettre un quota des index des
non je crois que il faut véritablement
que on comprenne bien que il y a une
vision différente à avoir parce qu'après
si vous mettez des quotas pour les plus
anciens faut remettre pour les plus
jeunes on en sort plus la liberté les
mesures que l'on propose sont pas des
mesures contraignantes peut-être sur la
méthode admettons que l'Assemblée
nationale ne reprenne pas votre
amendement admettons ça peut arriver ça
peut arriver qu'est-ce que vous demandez
au gouvernement ou Emmanuel Macron de
passer cette réforme de retraite par un
texte spécifique ou par le budget de la
Sécu non il faut passer par un test
spécifique d'ailleurs nous on passe par
le biais du PLFSS en proposant des
mesures parce qu'on peut pas faire
autrement c'est un texte budgétaire mais
la philosophie de cette réforme c'est de
dire et la différence avec Emmanuel
Macron c'est non on veut pas aller
jusque 65 ans et deuxièmement c'est au
partenaires sociaux ils ont déjà fait
preuve de responsabilité prenez la jjko
elle a bien sûr faire en sorte de
prendre des mesures à un moment parce
que parce que il fallait équilibrer un
système de retraite bien pourquoi ne pas
aller jusqu'à 65 ans parce que Emmanuel
Macron il parle de 65 ans même si
maintenant il ouvre la porte à 64
Édouard Philippe lui dit même 65 66 67
pour vous c'est non non nous pensons que
si on prend les mesures à temps de façon
pas trop brutal on peut éviter d'aller
jusque 65 ans bah ça mérite qu'on s'y
penche quand même parce que sinon
effectivement mais je rappelle que dans
les pays voisins où il part déjà parfois
tard en retard il retravaillent après à
70 ans il faut du cumul emploi retrait
très bien vous travaillez sur le cumul
emploi retraite mais franchement si un
système qui n'oblige pas les personnes
en retraite à retard travailler c'est
quand même mieux et si on prend pas les
mesures bon on va arriver à ça ce qu'on
fait l'exemple de la Suède la Suède mais
je peux vous dire qu'elle 70 ans ils
reprennent des petits boulots pour
pouvoir avoir une retraite plus
confortable nous on veut pas être ça
voilà donc on a quelque chose qui nous
paraît équilibré qui permet justement
quand le système est mieux financé de
des mesures compensant les difficultés
peuvent rencontrer certaines professions
à rester en emploi à un âge plus avancé
que ça soit un texte Haddock et que ça
passe pas par un texte budgétaire qui
dit texte à Doc ça veut dire que le
gouvernement grillerait une cartouche
sur le 49-3 pour ne pas avoir à utiliser
le 49-3 il va avoir besoin de soutien
des républicains et ce qu'il aura alors
attention
il y a ce problème là mais moi je vois
bien comment ça va se passer on va faire
d'un côté une réforme budgétaire
pour la partie d'équilibre des retraites
étant une réforme financière en PLF
rectificatif on peut manger un 49 francs
peut utiliser un 49-3
dans la partie dans la partie des prises
en compte de la solidarité pour l'emploi
des seniors les mesures à prendre vous
faites un texte différent qui peut
trouver un consensus parce que tout le
monde sera d'accord pour prendre en
charge handicap avoir des réversions qui
soient plus équitables la prise en
compte des enfants etc il y a un tas de
mesures qui peuvent être pris et là les
personnes associées peuvent y travailler
donc je fais confiance au gouvernement
pour trouver les solutions nécessaires
moi je pense que ça ça va être comme ça
mais ce qui nous intéresse là-dessus
nous c'est pas de faire un coup
politique je pense que nous au Sénat
depuis longtemps on avertit que il faut
faire quelque chose pour les retraites
et que ça sert à rien de proposer des
réformes telles qu'elle avait été
proposées où on change tout à vouloir
tout changer ou ne change rien
merci Steve merci à tout à l'heure on
reparlera des internes en médecine et ce
sera évidemment dans le club dans une
demi-heure un dernier mot sur un autre
texte c'est la réforme de l'assurance
chômage puisqu'il y a député sénateur on
trouvait un accord sur cette réforme
c'est un texte qui module les
allocations en fonction de la
conjoncture du marché du travail vous
aviez durci le texte en séance le groupe
LR vous avez été suivi par la commission
mix paritaire notamment sur pas
d'allocation pour un CDD qui refuse de
CDI à post égal à salaire égal on
imagine que vous êtes satisfait il y a
quand même un petit bémol le Ligier du
socle qui lui voyait un risque il dit
les demandeurs d'emploi n'accepteront
pas de contrats courts pour ne pas être
enfermé dans un emploi qu'est-ce que
vous en dites
justement on nous dit qu'il faut prendre
des mesures pour ne pas avoir de contre
à court quand on trouve des mesures pour
avoir le contrats vous avez développé
des contrats courts non s'il y a pas de
volonté d'appliquer le texte qui a été
décidé par les parlementaires c'est
grave hein mais je fais confiance à
Olivier du sable pour mettre en
application ce qui a été proposé on peut
plus comprendre dans notre société que
les entreprises toutes les entreprises
que vous rencontrez ont besoin de main
d'oeuvre alors faut mieux rémunérer les
genres entre l'emploi plus attractif
mais c'est aussi inciter les gens à
prendre le travail parce que on a pris
une certaine habitude faut dire où on a
des dispositions que les gens ont bien
compris et qui font qu'on travaille pas
forcément à temps plein etc c'est le
système qu'il faut faire évoluer
si on change le système et les gens ils
vont rechercher de l'emploi et je pense
que là ce qui a été trouvé et bien si
vraiment incitatif pour ceux ou qui sont
en CDI ou qui sont un intérim à un
moment ou on leur propose un emploi
quand même à temps complet et bien ils
sont dans les dispositions sont prises
pour qu'il l'acceptent merci
cette première
de désert médicaux dans le club
d'étatoires le gouvernement et le Sénat
propose des mesures mais peut-on se
passer de contraintes ce sera le débat
des bas avec la scène attriste
corinnebert et le député Guillaume
Garraud merci beaucoup René Paul Savary
d'avoir été avec nous c'est Alexis
Corbière qui nous rejoint
[Musique]